you think that's his job to make sure
that you know if you don't follow his
brand of tolerance that you shouldn't
have a seat at the table of Western
civilization that your daughter is
intolerant because she doesn't want to
see someone's pecker right at face level
several people who obviously even be
following this but we didn't have time
to get into this because Epstein
happened earlier in the week Chris Cuomo
was recently Pro approached to the
restaurant the Fredo thing let me
refresh your memory turns up the Goomba
[Music]
he was really trying to perpetuate the
negative Italian stereotype and went too
far and you can see me look at the
camera look I'm gonna pull you down the
stairs in aw crap I'm just one step shy
of saying I'm gonna crowbar your kneecap
and he's sitting there just what a punk
yeah well as he says Punk couch yeah
yeah there you go that's some kind of
funny we asked that rhetorical question
like why don't you do that when you're
trying to fight somebody like yeah this
I'm a believer in just either fights if
you're going or if I don't strike or
don't but don't ask rhetorical questions
what if I called you punk cha how do you
feel just say Punk bitchin I don't
casting punch fro but your ass are you
expecting an actual answer how about I
throw you down the flight of stairs yes
for me I wouldn't like I think the guy
who called him Fred if he was in fact
and we're hearing reports it may be he
wasn't with his wife and kid listen I
think there's a ceasefire when you're
out in public and you shouldn't be
berating somebody I think the guy who
did it was a dick and trying to set him
up that being said he of course Chris
Cuomo should be able to allow cooler
heads to prevail so that's why it's time
for this month's installment of what
[Music]
so today top five reasons
half-asian Ville having similar
bewitchments monitors broken so he's
lean we're supposed to do five but we
actually add seven and then we just
rounded it down to six I don't know why
so I'm number six this is we have video
of video graphic evidence for all this
Chris Cuomo said that nathan phillips
remember the math quest guy yeah he
actually said on air that nathan
phillips wanted to defuse the situation
by banging the drum in the covington
kids face and the kid made the wrong
decision by standing and smiling so this
is how he frames it and and he wants you
to think that my god is natural
journalist
nathan phillips apparently wanted to
defuse the tension and he walked up with
exactly that and surely the kid Nick
Sandman he doesn't seem to be afraid but
he did make a choice and that was to
make it into a standoff what was it
legal
sure that's not my sure but that's not
my test black don't say you know me I
don't have to tell you twice he stood no
you know you didn't tell us many times
what is your test Chris Cuomo well if
you need to ask you're not ready you're
not yet ready to hear what well what are
you some fake Goomba mr. miyagi piece of
[ __ ]
wax on awesome by the way it's not only
legal he was in the right yes guy
effectively assaulted him and this is
what's so important to me as Chris Cuomo
really does of you if you see him on
Twitter he claims to be a journalist he
doesn't though there is no kind of bias
this is what's insane to me I don't have
a problem if you're right or if you're
left just don't lie to me admit it don't
it America
let's go to reason number five I think
we have a video of this one where he
claimed that America first and the term
nationalist these terms are actually
phrases equivalent to not they're bad
not that might be dog whistles
concentration camps one point of
pushback before I get to you Angela you
did not have similar problems with the
phrase America first which is equally
stained or the word nationalist now
which is equally stained no yes as a
matter fact I totally disagree that it's
a stain word as a matter of fact you may
be American now well no I'm not wrong
you
you don't get to define what NASA mean
there's their credibility hangs in the
balance from it from an anchor who can
be fooled by basic oppositeday reverse
psychology no no yes no yes yes dad
gummit
what have it season for MSA it's
equivalent to concentration camps when a
guy responds perfectly reasoning
no not at all yes at all yes reason
number four I you know I should say this
but I just think we'll let the clip do
the talking he actually thinks that
remember how Donald Trump got all kinds
of flack for saying you know I'm not
talking about the white supremacists or
the white nationalists they should
absolutely be condemned totally
but then he talked about the people who
the person was like both sides yeah yeah
well actually if you watch more of the
context and we can't provide you with
all the context because we don't have
that much time let's just show the clip
Chris Cuomo I mean you think Santa Fe's
is right
talk about an T far I've watched them in
the streets protesting in different
situations okay
there are certainly aspects of them that
are true to a cause that is a good cause
they want social justice they want
whatever they want in that context what
everyone what do that context context
social justice what does that even mean
yes anti-fur yes no change at the end of
a bed he also tweeted out a meme
suggesting the d-day soldiers in anta
pho were one in the same Wow let's not
forget oh my god okay if you forget it's
an insult to your people
all right you know either way while
we're mocking other people who claim to
be journalists I'm not one so hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because apparently that doesn't mean a
whole lot join one club lot of credit
calm /mo Club you're all kinds of
additional content including more
content with my half patient Larry bill
Richman subscribe on iTunes and Crowder
bits on YouTube or we upload the clips
here's another another example Cuomo
actually we don't have the it's a clip
and then his Twitter he mocks
effectively a rape victim yes for who
had a gun to defend herself in her
children she cut an ad for the NRA here
you go I knew I was going to die
and there was nothing I could do now I'm
a mother of two and if that creditor or
anyone else tries to harm me or my
family they have to come through my
firearm first and then Chris Cuomo
responded with only in America
responding to that video yes yes is that
a guy correct as opposed to UK what she
could be throwing chicken strips because
she can't even exactly she got raped she
can defend herself now she's God thing
when we talk about you talk about social
justice you talk about equality I you
just talk about in the aunt of a clip
you know they punch random passers-by at
will in the face about equality for
women being able to protect themselves
yes the only thing that can allow a
woman to be stronger than a man there
you go is it good but none of this is
basic nothing Cuomo says is ever based
on verifiable evidence or truth from
Russia to the idea that women shouldn't
be able to have a gun and this is one of
those tropes that turn out like you're
actually you're actually worse off just
for having a gun in now no it is
immediately debunked by simply looking
at defensive uses of firearms in the
country every year it's this was one
that's pretty I mean this is
particularly for even in the realm of
peace segments at least Chris Cuomo he's
got the he's you know he's good he's not
as he's not as offensively unattractive
as brian Stelter yeah that's true that's
true yeah like I got the Chris Cuomo the
nepotism thing yeah but brian Stelter i
I mean it's can someone explain it to me
in the comment section I'm also still
not convinced that he's straight
so anyway Cuomo did say this was
something else he said that the offering
thoughts and prayers was the equivalent
to mocking mass shooting victims and
then it gets even if you think well
that's pretty rough for a journalist
right it gets even worse there you go
the only consensus there is is in a
canard and here it is first you're not
to offer my thoughts and prayers because
that's what you do when you offer
thoughts and prayers seriously you mock
those who lost loved ones what would it
take how about a stadium full of
children of the most influential people
in our society all holding no puppies
what if they were all shot or killed
would we act oh don't be ridiculous to
suggest something like is it is it
ridiculous oh my god
no no yes sorry come on you made it too
easy for me yeah is this how in the
world does he get away with mafia
equivalent marring for people for
thoughts and prayers as opposed to what
you're gonna do Kris :
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do well support the assault weapon Ben
oh so you'll send your thoughts to your
representatives yeah to support a piece
of legislation that makes a gun like
this illegal and legal legal illegal
let's just go word someone's prayers to
the higher power that most people on
planet earth believe in is more silly
than you hoping wishing and living and
hoping and being a piece in your mind
hoping that someone signs a bill that
won't be affected at all and by the way
when he talks about people in a stadium
with puppies and we shut I don't talk
about a non-sequitur but this isn't not
in the mind of a crazy piece but he says
imagine the most influential people in
the world yeah I mean that's not the
crux of this now story here this
hypothetical it's shooting the puppies I
don't care if Podesta's holding them and
this is what's so dangerous you can seem
talking about the Australian buyback and
it doesn't feel as audience and on the
fact that it's mandatory that isn't it
doesn't ban and the real danger here is
you know everyone rachel maddow at
people's will why don't you take I don't
have a problem with Rachel Maddow
because people know where where she
lines up some people namely one more
time with CNN people in airports who've
apparently had their eyes duct-taped
open because that's the viewership we're
talking about here yep they don't
necessarily know that Cuomo is bias
right so this guy goes out there and
claims to be an actual journalist and
everything that we've just heard is a
narrative that he's allowed to frame
that he goes out there and he decides
what information or at least at one
point right that's why these people CNN
NBC Universal Viacom all these companies
want to make sure this show like this
doesn't exist because at one point in
time all you had was Chris Cuomo yeah
you said Walter Cronkite was any better
he was better at disguising it a little
bit yeah but that's what he's doing here
in case in point he wants to determine
how you view the news and normally how
you view it
but ultimately what kind of speech is
permissible which brings me to we don't
have a video clip but I think this is
the word saying that Cuomo has ever done
and again this goes to him trying to
manipulate and control news and I'm not
talking about some some government
come in front of my controller I got
heart I got blood pumping through my
heart I'm a human I'm just saying this
they form propaganda oh yeah methylene
it whole exclusive alex jones interview
available my club is like a whole hour
it's great um because he wanted to
reframe language here in saying that
twelve-year-old girls who don't want to
see penises in the locker room are
bigots here you go look at that i wonder
if she has a problem of her
overprotective and intolerant dad teach
tolerance oh there you go because this
is chris homo right in his job he thinks
that he think it's his job to make sure
that you know if you don't follow his
brand of tolerance that you shouldn't
have a seat at the table of western
civilization that your daughter is
intolerant because she doesn't want to
see someone's pecker right at face level
with her permeable contacts right it's
just it's remarkable to me hey there
youtube viewer subscribe to the channel
hit the notification bell if you're
already subscribed to this channel
because that lets you know when new
videos come out and they don't show up
on the youtube search feed also there
are videos playing in boxes here click
one of those just of all the things that
i just mentioned all you have to do is
one and if you don't I will run for the
United States presidency under the one
one thousand sixty four percent Cherokee
Party I have yet to pick my VP